[Music]
the ghosts are moving tonight restless
hungry may i introduce myself i'm once
imprinted in just a minute i'll show you
the only really haunted house until
since it was built a century ago seven
people including my brother have been
murdered in it since then i've owned the
house I've only spent one night there
and when they found me in the morning
I was almost dead I'm Fredrik Lauren and
I've rented the house on Haunted Hill
tonight so that my wife can give a party
a haunted house party she's so amusing
there'll be food and drink and ghosts
and perhaps even a few murders you're
all invited if any of you will spend the
next 12 hours in this house I'll give
you each $10,000 or your next of kin in
case you don't survive
ah but here come our other guests
it was my wife's idea to have our guests
come in funeral cars
[Music]
she's so amusing her sense of humor is
shall we say original I dreamed up a
hearse it's empty now but after a night
in the house I'll haunted him who knows
this is Lance Schroeder a test pilot so
no doubt a brave man but don't you think
you can be much braver if you're paid
for it and I happen to know that Lance
needs the 10,000 I'll give him if he's
brave enough to stay all night
this is Ruth bridges you've no doubt
read her column in the newspapers she
says a reason for coming to the party is
to write a feature article on ghosts
she's also desperate for money Gamble's
you've already met Watson Pritchard a
man living in mortal fear of a house and
yet he is risking his life to spend
another night here I wonder why he says
for money
this is dr. David Trent a psychiatrist
he claims that my ghosts will help his
work on hysteria but don't you see a
little touch of greed there around the
mouth and eyes
this is Nora Manning I picked her from
the thousands of people who work for me
because she needed the 10,000 more than
most supports her whole family isn't she
pretty the party's starting now and you
have until midnight to find the house on
Haunted Hill
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well where is everybody
he didn't a very warm welcome is it only
the ghosts in this house are glad we're
here
are we all strangers to each other don't
you two know each other
I'm afraid I don't even know your name I
know I'm Annie Lance Schroeder its
Frederick Law and a friend of yours I've
heard of him but I've never met him I
work for one of his companies but I've
never seen him I've never met the man
either just a phone call you knowing no
but then you're the only one of us who
does I don't know him all the details
about running the house were done by
mail
he's quite wealthy isn't he millions and
five wives I believe four I think so far
$50,000 party for only five people is a
little steep even for a millionaire well
if I'm gonna heart anybody this would
certainly be the house I'd do it in who
close the door
[Music]
this thing's made of solid steel
[Music]
Anabelle our guests are here
unfortunately still alive
is your face on yet dust and dirt
everywhere
the water barely trickles couldn't you
have had the place clean atmosphere
darling you know how ghosts are they
never tidy up and that's a very fetching
outfit but hardly suitable for a party
I'm not going to the party they spend
the night ghost party was your idea
remember since it's gonna cost me
$50,000 I want you to have fun the party
was my idea until you invited all the
guests while the strangers were none of
our friends friends do we have any
friends no you're a jealousy together
end I had a reason for inviting each
guest I wanted kind of a cross-section
from psychiatrist to typist
and from drunk to jet pilot they share
one thing they all need money now let's
see if they're brave enough to pan it
and you call this a party could be why
do you always do that it spoils the
champagne it might explode never does
well you guarantee that that isn't funny
Frederick make a good headline playboy
kills wife with champagne cork will you
join me no thank you
just a sip right improve your humor my
humor is behind Thanks and I haven't
poisoned it it's always good to know
that
[Applause]
have some you'll enjoy the party more
come on
your trust is so touching and I'm not
going to party of all my wives you're
the least agreeable but still alive hmm
would you go away for a million dollars
in tax free you want it all don't you
I deserve it all if jealousy isn't
tax-free your possessiveness is
maddening if ever a man had grounds for
divorce but can't prove them the time
will come you don't slip up one of these
days think so you found this long enough
you remember the fun we had when you
poisoned me something you ate the doctor
said yes arsenic on the rocks Annabelle
you'd do it again if you thought you
could get away with it wouldn't you
darling what makes you think that
something about you yeah that hanging is
very uncomfortable in case you get any
more ideas
don't let the ghosts and the ghouls
disturb you darling
darling the only ghoul in the house is
you and don't sit up all night thinking
of ways to get rid of me it makes
wrinkles
[Music]
[Applause]
this is what she used on my brother and
her sister act him to pieces
we found parts of the bodies all over
the house and places you wouldn't think
funny things the heads have never been
found
hands and feet and things like that but
no heads the white probably in a rage
threatened her husband with a knife and
then carried away by hysteria took a
swing at him and simply went on from
there she certainly went on how many
people did she kill mr. Pritchard only
to her husband and her sister no one
else was here so there are two loose
heads just floating around in here so
what you can hear them at night they
whisper to each other and then cry since
our host isn't here with anyone care
that makes me a drink
certainly what will you have good
evening I'm your host Frederick Loren
since we're all strangers to each other
let's get acquainted with the drink
shall we mr. Loren I advise you to call
this party off now the ghosts are
already moving and that's a bad son let
me apologize for my wife she'll join us
later whether you have scotch and doctor
I'll have the same now before the party
begins let's go over the details
the caretakers will leave at midnight
locking us in here until they come back
in the morning once the door is locked
there's no way out the windows have bars
that a jail would be proud of and the
only door to the outside locks like a
vault there's no electricity no phone no
one within miles so no way to call for
help like a coffin so if any of you
decide not to stay for the party you
must let me know before midnight of
course if you leave I shan't be able to
pay you anything
I'm interested in your reasons for this
party aside from the pleasant company
ghosts doctor I think everyone wonders
what they would do if they saw a ghost
and now my wife has given us all the
opportunity to find out hmm
amusing ghosts etc being only creations
of hysteria your party should be a
success Pritchard here promises us
genuine ghosts seven now maybe more
before morning that's cheerful four men
have been murdered in this house and
three women you planned your party very
well mr. Loren four of us am in three of
women that goes for everybody
don't pictured why don't you take us on
a tour through the house and let's see
what happens
[Music]
see that stained blood a young girl was
killed here and whatever got her wasn't
human
don't stand there where
[Music]
it's too late they've marked you
ridiculous
through probably leaks well that must be
brother it is who would want me I would
say any self-respecting male ghost I
hope it doesn't come back
well mr. Pritchard you're the life of
the party he hasn't even started yet
wasn't there a man who threw his wife
into a wine VAT or something that was in
the cellar there's been a murder almost
every place in this house
all this belong to a mr. Norton who
didn't die here she was electrocuted
later mr. Norton didn't do experimenting
with wines but his wife didn't think was
any good so he filled a VAT with acid
threw her in she was supposed to stay
down but the bones came up it's a funny
thing but none of the murders here were
just ordinary just shooting was stabbing
they've all been sort of wild violent
different God she didn't fall in you
mean there's still acid in there
[Music]
[Applause]
destroys everything with hair and flesh
just leaves the bones my it's dry and
dusty down here okay third a cure for
that big come on how'd you get invited
to this party go on
I mean what'd he tell you mr. Lawrence
said everybody he'd get ten thousand
dollars but he didn't say anything about
being locked in no he just made a deal
with me on the phone but nothing about
having to stay aren't you gonna stay if
I don't I lose $10,000 I'm gonna stay to
[Applause]
$10,000 yeah you believe in ghosts
I don't know well I agree with what that
doc says you can spook yourself I've
done a complaint
see things that weren't really there Oh
were they what are you gonna do with
your ten thousand if we get it what do
you mean if we get it won't pay us if we
stay oh sure he will
ten thousand is no more to him than a
nickel is that we were in an automobile
accident now I'm the only one in the
family who can make any money boy I've
never seen so many doors
closet bottles does it go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please Lance is gone and there's a ghost
Freeman please come on did you say max
is gone gone where
[Music]
[Music]
you are right nothing that money won't
cure I must have mr. bump my head I'm
the only way to bump your head in here
to run head-on into the wall you didn't
do that did you
let's get a band adjustment
[Music]
I wonder why they didn't kill him who he
didn't bump his head
they they
[Applause]
[Music]
Nora when you came in you said something
about a ghost there was something what
did it look like well it was wearing a
black thing that went all the way to the
floor
weren't you a little frightened at the
time but yes that mr. Loren is hysteria
but then doctor how do you explain what
happened to Lance was that hysteria -
you better get that checked in today sir
thanks doc wait for me alone the ghosts
are coming closer mr. Loren
you really believe in your pet ghosts
don't you pitch in before the nights
over you will - would you like a drink
Lance at no thanks I'd like one scotch
and are you really going to pay anyone
who stays all night certainly $10,000
will it be much red tape delay in a
hurry dear frankly yes or practically
there you are my dear
[Applause]
someone or something was in here when I
came in of where and if the door was
locked how did it get out what you saw
might have been a ghost Nora but what
was in here with me was no ghost I don't
know I was so scared
it sound different to you yes three six
nine twelve twelve feet three six I'm
gonna knock on the other wall would you
hear me you knock on this wall
[Music]
[Music]
where'd it come from come in here
[Music]
what if it ran out of here I'd have seen
land it doesn't run it just float you
ever did
why didn't I see it you don't believe me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Annabelle Loren
you must be miss Manning I realized this
was a very unusual and I'm afraid very
dull party wouldn't you like to freshen
up this is your room depressing isn't it
I doubt if I'll spend much time you
going to rain perfect atmosphere for my
husband's party why did you come here he
said he'd give me ten thousand dollars
why did he pick you I don't know
my supervisor just came and said I'd
been invited how long have you known as
me I just met him tonight so why are you
what were you doing wandering around by
yourself well I was in the cellar with
Lance mr. Schroeder
I just left that's all don't do it again
don't go anywhere in this house by
yourself now picture Bay's not come by
for you in a few minutes but you're in
danger we all are who I hope your sake
you never find her
[Music]
I'm Annabelle Loren you're looking for
something not exactly are you the doctor
no no I'm not Schroeder the pilot you've
hurt yourself oh it's just a bump on the
head which is my room I believe this is
it
Thank You mrs. Loren Annabelle Lance
[Applause]
you were with the young girl in the
cellar why was she so upset was she and
you don't look like the type to around
bumping his head what really happened
does well Nora thought she saw a ghost
but I didn't see anything
she was just frightened and mad at me I
think I kidded her about it I wouldn't
joke about anything else that happens
here tonight
now don't tell me you're taking all this
seriously aren't you all right I'd like
to find out what hit me yes I need help
me I count on you yeah
sure I guess so look what's going on
here anyway I mean what is with this
party good this is no party he's
planning something your husband how
shiny what it was must be pretty big if
he's gonna lay out 50,000 the money
doesn't mean anything he has a reason
for getting us all up here to this
dreadful old house what for he doesn't
even know us
maybe that's exactly why you're here
what can you get away with oh he thinks
the big money like his can get away with
anything you know of course it I'm his
fourth wife first simply disappeared the
other two died Lance I don't want to
join them you mean he Oh his doctor said
they died of heart attacks two girls in
their twenties well what can he do my
husband - sometimes insane with jealousy
nothing matters doing it please be
careful what he hurt you he would kill
me if he could
[Music]
and Abed you missing all the fun
Nora Manny was almost killed by a
falling chandelier the pilot bashed his
head in
is he badly hurt the saturnine
psychiatrist bandaged him up don't you
want to go in consoling she do most men
in your fashion it's a clever Frederic
it's a lie awake nights wondering why I
married you was rather a mistake you
didn't marry me dear I married you
unpleasant but no mistake hurry up
Frederick with the last time I'm not
going to your party for the last time
it's not my party but yours and you are
going I am NOT ready to know are you
ready dear yes damn you
but you adore me as much of a Baku yeah
all you wanna be is a lovely Widow it's
almost time to lock up the house then
your party will really begin
I wonder how it'll end it's close to
midnight Lance okay
I'll be down in a minute your host Mandy
it's almost midnight Nora we're all
going to get together down in the living
room all right July I'll be right down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come with us come with us before he
kills you
[Music]
where's Laura miss Manning
[Music]
don't wanna stay here no no what
happened
let's Jonas slides and his wife they've
been caretakers here for years
she's blind Jenna I'm not going to stay
here
the doctor it looks like we have a real
case of hysteria on our hands try things
you just a little upset not hysterical
[Music]
good evening
hello Maddie this is my wife these are
our guests
Ruth bridges dr. Trent you know what
them Richard of course Nora Manning and
this is Lance Schroeder
what about the 10,000 I don't care you
want to kill me who wants to kill your
Lord may I have your attention please
I think you all remember the bargain we
made about staying all night ten
thousand dollars a piece if any of you
don't survive $50,000 will be divided
amongst the rest of you if I should die
you will be paid by my estate when the
door is locked from the outside by the
caretakers we'll all be forced to stay
in this house until morning if any of
you decide not to stay you must leave
with the caretakers now you won't have a
chance to change your minds later
because there'll be no way to get out I
don't want to stay wait
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it isn't midnight yet who told them they
could leave they never leave before
midnight they've gone now I was going to
ask you whether you wanted to stay or
not but it seems that the caretakers
have made the decision for you we're all
locked in now but I don't want to stay
I'm sorry my dear but it's too late now
darling haven't you had enough of the
silly game get some cars appear for
these people and let them go home but
pay them first this is your party
remember
in spite of my wife's faith in my
ability to do the impossible we will all
have to stay in this house until 8
o'clock in the morning but we have some
party favors for you in these little
coffins this is my wife's idea I must
say I think it's rather dangerous
alright suppose you all know how to use
one of these things but in case you
don't you just press down in this lever
with your thumb and then pull the
trigger you see they're loaded these are
no good against the dead only the living
[Music]
doctor dance
[Music]
Nora go ahead take it
miss produced
and here's your's dear I don't need it
it was your idea who knows you may want
to use it on me before this manager
[Music]
throw these guns away they won't doing
any good I agree with Pritchard on that
port although not for the same reason
dr. Trent don't you approve of our
little party favors suppose Nora had had
a gun when she mistook the blind woman
for a ghost I don't think anyone else is
going to walk around in total darkness
oh I'm sure we're not gonna go running
around the house shooting each other
aren't you who knows here makes people
do amazing things mr. Richard you said
your sister-in-law killed a man and a
woman here and cut them up you said they
found hands and feet but they never
found any hits would you like to see one
of those heads would you all like to see
one of those heads well just follow me
[Music]
darling I really don't need this
[Music]
just go look in my suitcase just go look
[Music]
buddy within there a woman's head Nora I
think you're a little upset would you
care for a sedative it's alright to
leave her back doctor
I wish you'd taken the sedative what do
you suppose you thought you saw they're
closing in on her look doc I think
somebody ought to stay with it there
could be a million people around it if
they wanted her they'd get her what if
he's right
he's too drunk to know what he's talking
about I wonder join you in a minute do
you think of it do any good if you went
in and talked to her do you think there
really was I had in their suitcase I
don't know thing like that would put me
right over the edge would you so stay up
here I mean in case she needs out all
right I'll be in my room just call it
Thanks
are you sure there are only seven people
in this house positive except the ghosts
I don't believe in ghosts nor in
frightening women in Nora's case it's
gone far enough
perhaps too far what do you suggest we
do about it doctor don't frighten her
anymore
[Music]
[Music]
Noora Noora
[Music]
Dora
[Music]
[Music]
what do you know about this they've
taken her in a little while she'll be
one of them
where's not where is she it's too late
it's too late you'll never find her
again Pritchard if you know where she is
you better tell me now gone she's gone
too then there's nothing you can do
about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it down
[Music]
Nora
[Music]
she's dead mr. Laurin
your wife hanged herself it's suicide
[Music]
please
[Music]
tried to kill me he grabbed me and
opiate put me in that room and then he
went away and left me who he thought I
was dead
who mr. Lord
are you sure about this I don't know it
was dark but it must've been him
has anybody seen you since he left you I
heard some people in that room but I
went by and nobody stopped mrs. Laurel
is dead
[Music]
Lauren said she committed suicide but I
think somebody killed
[Music]
I'm sure you've come to the same
conclusion I have yeah I think so let's
all have a meeting discuss what to do
the living room okay in a minute
I gotta go downstairs now you lock
yourself in here and don't let anybody
know you're here
he thinks you're dead he won't come here
and I'll get back as soon as I can
you'll be all right if you have to you
use it
[Music]
so beautiful so greedy so cold what are
you doing in here wait don't we what do
you mean coming in here I can put them
to take her away drunk they will have
you know what you're you're drunk all
right out with it Bridget why did you
come into this room I'm the only one who
understand understands what huh
you're a wife isn't there anymore she's
already joined them Bridget I've had
enough of your spook talk
get out you Sutton don't come back into
this room again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
where's what's your name Nora I didn't
disturb it since I don't think there's
concern sir no you're right
mr. Loren isn't there some way we can
get out of this house now no none at all
we could try breaking out the only door
the outside is made of steel the bars of
the windows are set in solid stone
the goddess day I'm not afraid of your
ghosts Bridget but I am afraid when we
came here a few hours ago the only thing
we had in common was a ten thousand
dollars we'd get now however we share
something else the depth of mrs. Loren
so far tonight
one of us was almost killed by a falling
chandelier one of us was mysteriously
slugged one of us has been driven to the
brink of absolute hysteria and one of us
is dead were these accidents suicide and
we must stay here for six more hours six
are six of us time Anna it'll be next--
how will it happen let me ask you a
question doctor you were the first one
to see my wife there did you also see
anything that she could have climbed up
on and then jumped no did any of them
there was no
how then did she get up there so high
exactly mr. Lauren how she couldn't have
pulled herself up there she couldn't
have dropped from the ceiling do you
think your wife killed herself no she
was murdered by one of you or you mr.
Lauren to deliberately kill someone you
must have a reason we were all strangers
to your wife only you had a motive for
murder my husband hasn't it some time
wanted to kill his wife what husband
hasn't had a thousand opportunities to
do it in such a way so that he'd never
be suspected I'm not such a fool is to
hang my wife from a ceiling by a rope
the fact remains that you are one of us
murdered mrs. Lauren and that's a matter
for the police so how do we get the
police that's my point we can't until
morning what began as a silly party
given by an eccentric has now involved
us all in murder once Prichard may be
right if another murders in the works
let's stop it now
another murder why not maybe one of us
saw too much why should even a
millionaire want to give each of us ten
thousand dollars to spend one night in a
gloomy old house to see some ghosts have
a party
no have you finished trying me doctor
and is the verdict guilty of murder ah
this isn't getting us anywhere somebody
killed mrs. Lauren we know that one of
us is guilty and the rest of us are
innocent okay now what we have to do for
the next six hours is protect ourselves
from each other you really think I don't
think anything I just know that I'm
going to my room and if anybody comes in
I'll shoot him or and if we all stay in
our rooms we'll be safe because the
innocent will have no reason to leave
his room and the guilty will admit his
guilt if he or she does and we all have
guns and we're all agree I wish this
night were over
[Applause]
groans guns I tell you it doesn't make
any difference
they aren't through with us yet
[Applause]
[Music]
what's the use of saying goodnight
[Music]
okay
[Music]
goodnight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Lauren it's me Lance
okay they've all gone to their rooms and
lock themselves in plants I've been
thinking it was so dark down there maybe
it wasn't mr. Lord it was M all right he
tried to kiss you and he didn't kill his
wife how can you be so sure
she tried to warn me asked me to help
the doc thinks he's gonna try and kill
one of us now there must be a way out of
this place and I'm gonna find it and get
the police before he does I'm going with
you well if he finds out you're alive no
Nora you're safer here than anyplace
else I just lock yourself in and keep
quiet I find a way out I'll come back
and get you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and admission of guilt dr. certainly not
as either somebody else on his house of
one of us has left his room did you hear
anything
organ music that and someone walking you
got yours ready
you look downstairs and I'll look up
here why not together they may be only
minute seconds left of someone's life
why waste time
[Applause]
[Music]
it's almost over tiling every detail was
perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
what's happening we've done it a perfect
crime beautiful her she killed him not
yet but she will
[Applause]
get me out of this hanging harness but
taking that girl so long what time is it
at first I couldn't get Nora to want to
protect herself with a gun after you
appeared at the window everything began
to work just as we'd planned
you were wonderful just a touch that
finally drove her into complete hysteria
it'll be worth all of our planning
darling where's Nora know what's
happening on the way to the cellar so
scared she'll shoot the first thing that
moves and Frederick on his way to the
cellar - David are you sure none of them
will suspect us of what an hysterical
girl accidentally shoots somebody who
would suspect that we planned it that
way that we drove her to it what about
my suicide but just a ghost party gag
will claim it was a dummy since I'm the
only one who touched you and the
caretakers well they had no idea what
they were really doing what about Nora
she's not stupid you know darling
believe me everything we planned is
working perfectly Nora is sure Frederick
murdered you she thinks Frederick
attacked her in the cellar not me
and now Nora's almost out of a mine with
fear the heads the music your hanging I
tell you when Frederick walks in there
she'll shoot him it's taking too long
David you ought to be there
[Applause]
when you hear the shot come down to the
cellar
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
David David
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
last you got it all everything I had
even my life but you are not going to
live to enjoy come with me
butters come with me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
night doctor night Annabelle crime you
to plan was indeed perfect only the
victim is alive and the murderers in not
it's a pity you didn't know when you
started your game of murder that I was
playing - there must be some way to get
in here it's right along here some what
I've shot mr. Loren he's down in the
wine cellar I don't think so it's here
be the life you didn't shoot anyone my
dear I loaded your gun with blanks I can
tell you all now
Trenton my wife were planning to kill me
they failed
Trent tried to throw me in the VAT my
wife stumbled and fell I'm ready for
justice to decide if I'm innocent or
guilty
[Music]
[Applause]
now they're 9 that be more many more
coming from me now and then they will
come to you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]